il semblerait que les fêtes pascales et
donné le coup d'envoi de la saison
touristique en limousin annonciateur de
vos jours et de vacances ces campeurs
s'arrête sur le terrain de limoges près
des bords de vienne
le camping est un peu un rendez vous
européens anglais allemands belges des
français y plantent leur tente et il
part que leurs caravanes
ce camping de l'image offre aux
touristes des installations sanitaires
modernes est des équipements sportifs
terrain de volley-ball m inigo le
terrain de camping offre aux touristes
une étape reposante étape que l'on met
souvent à profit pour visiter des
manufactures de porcelaine ou des
ateliers des mayer et pour les limousins
qui ne sont pas encore en congés ces
images de détente préfigurent déjà la
prochaine bataille